an American jailed in Egypt is back in
the u.s. this morning after an
intervention by the Trump administration
30 year old aid worker aya Hijazi was
held in an Egyptian prison for nearly
three years on charges of assault
torture and trafficking human rights
groups called all those claims unfounded
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with how the negotiations unfolded
Margaret good morning good morning Nora
well aya Hijazi moves to Egypt from her
Virginia hometown in order to help
homeless children but she ended up in
jail as part of a widespread crackdown
on activists by Egypt's president
president el-sisi has been somebody
that's been very close to me from the
first time I met him earlier this month
President Trump welcomed Egyptian
president Abdel Fattah al-sisi to the
White House effectively resetting a
strained relationship with the Middle
Eastern allies and look forward to
working with the President as part of
that reset the White House decided to no
longer make human rights a point of
public dispute with Egypt but behind the
scenes pressed for the release of
American aid worker aya hijazi how can
somebody so pure so innocent trying to
help end up in jail for three years
basile Hejazi is eyes brother we spoke
with him prior to her release there has
been a crackdown on a lot of civil
society groups is that in any way
related to what happened to your sister
there are numbers that say 40,000 people
have been arrested why ayah and why this
NGO we still don't know but the general
atmosphere of Egypt allowed that to
happen then general CeCe's military
seized power in 2013 and imprisoned tens
of thousands of activists journalists
and aid workers that widespread
crackdown prompted the Obama
administration to suspend some of the
more than 1 billion in annual US aid to
Egypt last Sunday a Cairo Court dropped
all charges against Hijazi
also released was he jazzy's husband
Egyptian national Mohamed Hassanein
there is no reason for anybody not to
want her to be free because as a
humanitarian and she did nothing but
now basil and his sister will meet
President Trump and his daughter Ivanka
here at the White House later today
their lawyer sent a statement to CBS
News saying that he is thankful for the
help from President Trump but also many
lawmakers who have intervened over the
years and Nora what's interesting here
is that president Sisi long claimed that
his hands were tied on this case and it
was up to Egypt's courts and this
morning defense secretary mattis is
emphasizing this was ultimately the
court's decision not a negotiated
release but it was up to the courts to
free her really interesting Margaret
thank you so much